now that we know that we can view
interest rates as essentially the price
of renting money i want to go through a
bunch of scenarios just so we can
understand how different
things that happen in the economy might
affect interest rates so i'll just draw
a bunch of supply and demand curves
right over here and once again we're
talking about the market for essentially
renting money so that right over here is
the price of money which we know is the
interest rate
the interest rate on the vertical axis
and then in the horizontal axis we have
the quantity of money that is borrowed
or lent in a given time period
so quantity and this is in a given time
period that is borrowed or lent so
borrowed quantity borrowed
let's just say in
a
quantity borrowed in a year and we know
that there's some
if we just want to draw a demand curve
our starting demand curve the first few
dollars out in the economy people are
willing to pay a very high interest rate
on them and then every incremental
dollar after that people will get less
marginal benefit they might not find as
good of a place to put that money
they're borrowing it for a reason
they're either going to borrow it to
consume to buy something that they
always wanted that they think will make
them happy or more likely they're
borrowing it to invest it and hopefully
getting a return higher than what they
are borrowing at and so you have a
marginal benefit curve that look would
be downward sloping something like that
maybe it might look something like maybe
it looks something like that so that is
our demand curve or our marginal benefit
curve and the supply curve and once
again this is the exact same logic we
use with the demand supply curve for any
good or service for money might look
like this
those first few dollars someone has a
very low opportunity cost of lending it
out so they're willing to lend it at a
very low interest rate and then every
incremental dollar after that there's
higher opportunity costs and so people
will lend it out at a higher and higher
rate and then you have a mark a market
equilibrium interest rate and so let me
copy and paste this and then we can
think about what happens in different
scenarios
so copy and paste
so now we have two scenarios that we can
work on and then let me just do one more
three scenarios now let's think of a
couple let's say that the central bank
of our country in the united states that
would be the federal reserve the central
bank prints more money and then decides
to lend out that money and that actually
is in the previous video i talked about
the central bank printing money and then
dropping it from helicopters that is not
how money is actually distributed it is
distributed when when central banks
print money the way that it enters into
circulation in most countries is that
the central bank then goes and
essentially lends that money the way
it's done in the u.s fed for the most
part they go out and buy government
securities which is essentially lending
money to the federal government and they
do that because that's considered to be
the safest investment but they go out
there and they lend money and so if some
it's more money so if this is our
original supply curve if this is our
original supply curve but now your
federal
your central bank is printing more money
and lending it out what is going to
happen over here well your supply curve
is going to shift to the right at any
given at any given price at any given
interest rate you're going to have a
larger quantity of money being available
so it might look something like it might
your new supply curve might look
something like that
and assuming that's the only change that
happens you see its effect your new
equilibrium price of money the rent on
money or the interest rate on money is
now lower and that's why when the when
the federal reserve says i want to lower
interest rates they do so by printing
money and and they print that money and
they lend it out in the market and that
essentially has the effect of lowering
interest rates now let's think about
another situation let's say so this is
this is the fed
fed prints
prints and lens and lens money lens
money and they're lending the money by
buying government bonds when you buy a
government bond you're essentially
lending that money to the federal
government and i've i've done other
videos on that where we go into a little
bit more detail on that now let's think
of another situation let's think about
consumer
savings
consumer savings
go down so one interesting thing about
savings savings and investment are two
opposite sides of the same coin so when
you save money so money you literally
put it into a bank
so that you have the whole financial
system right over here so this is the
financial system
financial system that money is then goes
out and it is lent to other people and
that for the most part hopefully
that money when it's lent is used to
invest in some way so this is lending
so if consumer savings goes down that
means that the supply of money will be
shifted to the left at any given price
or any given interest rate there will be
less money available so in this
situation our supply curve is shifting
to is shifting to the left and just that
would increase interest rates and then
you could even make an argument that if
consumer savings is going down consumers
are borrowing are going to borrow less
as well and you could argue that maybe
demand would go up as well and so your
your demand could go up and that would
make that would make the equilibrium
interest rate even even higher now let's
do another scenario let's say that
the federal government in an effort to
let's say that they they for whatever
reason they're trying to finance a war
or some type of public works project and
they don't want to raise taxes so the
government decides to borrow a lot more
money so the government
the government
the government is essentially going to
go into a deeper is going to expand its
deficit it's going to government is
going to borrow
borrow money
so here our supply isn't changing i'm
assuming that the central bank isn't
changing its policies how much it's
printing and and savings rates aren't
changing but the demand is going to go
up the government is borrowing money so
the government or it's going to borrow
more money than it was already doing so
at any given price the demand for
money is going to increase we're going
to shift to the right and our new
equilibrium interest rate the remember
the rental price of money is going is
going to go up so the whole point of
this is just to show you that you really
can think about money like any other
good or service if the supply of money
goes up
then the price then the price of money
which is interest rates will go down let
me write this down so if the supply if
the supply
goes up then the price which is just
interest rates
goes down
if the demand goes up then the price
if the demand that if the demand goes up
then the price of money will go up so
interest rates
interest rates will go
interest rates will go up and then we
can think about all of the other
combinations where one demand goes down
then interest rates would go down which
is essentially just price the supply
went down interest rates would go up if
something becomes more scarce the price
of it goes up so the whole point of this
is to show that it's not that
complicated you'll see people say oh you
know government borrowing it's crowding
out other savings interest rates go up
and it sounds like something deep is
happening but it really they're just
talking about the supply and demand for
money and you just have to remember that
interest rates really are nothing more
than the rental price for money